était 2021 particulier dans les yvelines
avec l'instauration du fass sanitaires
depuis le 21 juillet il est obligatoire
pour accéder aux lieux de loisirs et de
culture comme les musées cinémas ces
derniers une chute de la fréquentation
de 70% il est aussi indispensable depuis
le 9 août pour aller manger au
restaurant sont et suivi des centres
commerciaux pas sanitaire exigé lundi 23
août dans 14 centres commerciaux des
yvelines pour être finalement suspendu
deux jours après par le tribunal
administratif de versailles
les yvelinois 2021 a été marquée aussi
par le sport ils sont revenus sourire
aux lèvres et médailles au cou les onze
athlètes yvelinois ont brillé lors des
jeux olympiques de tokyo qui se
déroulait du 23 juillet au 8 août un peu
plus de six médailles remportées comme
au triathlon avec trois représentants du
club de poissy qui ont obtenu la
médaille de bronze par équipes mixtes en
équitation même couleur de médailles
pour christopher 6 qui finit troisième
en concours complet par équipe les
yvelinois revenez dossier avec deux
médailles d'or handball pour le
versailles et valentin porte et en judo
par équipes mixtes guillaume chaîne du
club de sartrouville ils étaient
nombreux à venir applaudir tad edge poga
csars double vainqueur du tour ou encore
le champion du monde julian alaphilippe
la dernière étape du tour de france
s'élance et à chatou le 18 juillet c'est
la quatrième année consécutive que la
grande boucle s'élance des yvelines côté
politique le conseil d'état a enfin
tranché l'élection municipale à trappes
a été annulé mi août le feuilleton
judiciaire qui opposait le maire de
trappes à lire à b et son opposant au
conseil municipal othman menace roux a
pris fin à lire ab a été sanctionné par
ses actions de propagande qui ont faussé
le verdict des urnes de nouvelles
élections se tiendront les 10 et 17
octobre 2021 un nouveau duel s'annonce
entre les deux rivaux valérie pécresse a
annoncé jeudi 22 juillet sa candidature
pour l'élection présidentielle de 2000
22 elle veut et tout juste d'être réélu
pour un second mandat à la présidence de
la région ile de france son programme
sera basé sur la volonté de restaurer la
fierté française elle souhaite
participer à la primaire de la droite
c'est un chantier d'envergure qui débute
attrape le pont marcel cachin a été
démoli dans la nuit du 17 au 18 août il
surplombe et la route nationale 10 au
niveau de la mairie de la ville c'est
une première étape pour ce chantier de
six ans l'entrisme ans de la nationale
10 menée par la direction des routes
d'île de france et pour terminer ça a
été pour lui son plus bel été le chef
erwan restaurateur à bourdonner un
village yvelinois de 500 habitants a vu
les clients affluer dans son restaurant
grâce à une blogueuse qui a recommandé
sa cuisine et une vidéo vue plus de 37
millions de fois le chef est devenu
célèbre et fait salle pleine midi et
soir